can we really end poverty
i used to think that if enough people
donated lots of money
it could solve the problem of extreme
poverty
but only donating money to the ultra
poor doesn't really work
it's not really a long-term solution why
[Music]
i think it's because if they're given
money just like that
they may not really value it and if they
don't value the money that they have
they may end up spending their money on
things that they don't really need
and they may just lose the desire to
make a meaningful contribution to the
society
and it's not really sustainable because
the flow of money would just stop
one fine day but what do we mean by
ultra poor
the traditional definition says that the
ultra poor are the people
that live on less than two dollars a day
but lack of money is not their only
problem they're stripped of their
dignity
purpose and self-worth no community
accepts them
the former is called income poverty and
the latter
is called the poverty of hope so what's
the solution to address both
what if i tell you that the answer is a
two year graduation approach
no i'm not talking about any regular
graduation degree
a company named brac is using a two-year
graduation approach for women from ultra
poor families
in which they do four things first they
meet a woman's basic needs
by giving her cash or food this just
ensures the minimum to survive
second they provide her livestock and
teach her how to earn money from it
third they teach her to save budget
and invest this money that she earns and
lastly
brac helps to integrate her socially
which gives her a sense of belonging
each of these elements is crucial but
what works
best is the hope and sense of
possibility that women develop
and here's a fact that may startle you
since the program began in 2002
over 2 million women have lifted
themselves and their families out of
extreme poverty
that's close to 9 million people in all
to know more about brac read the
description below
and share this video with your friends
to tell them about this unique
two-year graduation approach that's
helping the ultra poor
if this video helped you please hit the
like button you see under this video
and do subscribe to our don't memorize
youtube channel